another day another bug in CS2 but by
God this one might just take the cake
teach me how to pick like Michael
Jackson what fittingly dubbed the MJ
Peak this new piece of movement Tech
which started as a unique issue for
specific types of keyboards has now
taken the community by storm and until
valve fixes it it might offer a
competitive Advantage here's how and why
it
[Music]
works last week I did a video talking
about what I thought to be unwarranted
criticisms about the current state of
CS2 but over the last few days that's
become slightly harder to
defend bomb has been
what counter terrorist win
um yo
is the hitbox debacle was quite the
spectacle last week as it turns out when
crouched and looking at the floor the
hit boxes of players would not align
accordingly causing dead-on shots to
completely Miss now as silly and
frustrating as it was it was quickly
patched by Valve which you love to see
however it almost seems to be completely
irrelevant now because it was
immediately taken over by an entirely
new even more amusing bug the Michael
Jackson
Peak
this clip of a CT doing what appeared to
be the king of Pops iconic lean did the
rounds on social media and when I first
saw it I thought it was fake we have
seen some cursed [__] of contorting
player models in games before and was
practically a staple in Gmod videos of
yester year but seeing it happen in a
competitive Counter-Strike 2 match is
not something I would have ever expected
like I said when I first saw it I
thought it was fake and then I saw it
again and again
what what and
again turns out it's completely real and
I like many others were immediately
wondering how the this is even possible
and what valve did to cause it well
while some have encountered this bug by
simply strafing with the op and quickly
scoping in Reddit user dark stunter
discovered how to consistently do it
with analog keyboards which may also
prove to be the root of the exploit
analog keyboards such as the wooting or
the Huntsman use infrared lasers to
actuate a keystroke rather than
tradition mechanical switches apparently
if you ever so slightly press a key
instead of fully inputting it it causes
the upper half of the body to move and
not the feet resulting in what looks
like a lean some have said this can also
be done using controllers thanks to its
analog stick in a 2018 video three-
clicks Philip highlighted a similar
method that could be used to make your
player move at different unintended
speeds it seems like these things
happened because both analog sticks and
analog keyboards have hundreds of states
of input rather than just on or off like
your more traditional keyboards valve
didn't account for this leading to the
issues now while it has long been
patched out of csgo my guess is that
valve let the analog varibles slip
through the cracks once again with CS2
however if you lack an analog keyboard
there is no need to feel left out
because Reddit user tick base made an
entire config for the MJ Peak so that it
could be achieved by anyone with any
keyboard since all these posts the MJ
Peak became something of a
Counter-Strike phenomenon sparking
hundreds of Smooth Criminal memes
culminating in this beautiful new
rendition of the CS2 logo which has not
only become the Reddit icon but now the
banner of the official Counter-Strike 2
Twitter account why because it's funny
it's literal slapstick humor in a video
game and even valve can't help but laugh
at themselves there was multiple times
while writing the script that I had to
pause from laughter now I have seen some
concerns online that if something this
ridiculous made its way past valve what
else is lying waight for us and honestly
yeah there's probably a lot more to come
but Silver Lining valve is patching
these things fairly quickly
Counter-Strike 2 is by no means a
finished product but whether you think
the game was released too quickly or not
I doubt valve is going to hit the undo
button so all we can really do is just
play through it and yes cheaters
performance issues they're a massive
bummer but for God's sakes sometimes all
you can have is a sense of
humor this has been like the first bug
where like the majority of the community
has just been like all right whatever
this is just funny all like the concern
trolling about like was this game
released too early like valve does not
give a [__] like they are willing to
make fun of themselves because they
legit just don't care they know they
they have a game that people are going
to play for decades and they're like
whatever this [__] is funny buy more
skins